while it often appears innocuous
on social media apps on retail sites or
search engines
the truth is that misinformation takes
away our freedom
to make informed decisions about our
health and the health of our loved ones
during the kobit 19 pandemic health
misinformation has led people
to resist wearing masks in high risk
settings
it's led them to turn down proven
treatments and to choose not to get
vaccinated
we've increased disinformation research
and tracking within the surgeon
general's office we're flagging
problematic posts
for facebook that spread this
information
white house flagging problematic posts
uh for facebook
that is problematic for some republicans
on capitol hill
i think it's really scary to have the
federal government of the united states
the white house
compiling lists of people organizations
whatever and then going to a private
company that by the way
is a monopoly facebook and saying you
need to censor you need to do something
about this you need to tell these users
these private users on a private company
what they can or cannot say i mean i
just think that this kind of
coordination between big government and
the big monopoly corporation boy that is
scary stuff and it really is censorship
brad
with that let's bring in our panel ben
domitch publisher of the federalist
kimberly strossel a member of the
editorial board at the wall street
journal
and harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman ceo of empowerment inclusion
capital uh kimberly let me start with
you your thoughts on all this
yeah i mean this is kind of remarkable
only last week we had the former
president of the united states
sue big tech arguing that they had
violated first amendment standards
because they were acting as arms of the
government
and here you have the white house and
jen saki you know giving talking points
that seem to leave
credence to lead credence to what is
kind of a novel legal theory
but you're going to see stuff like this
presented in court because
first amendment usually only normally
applies to the government but if you can
prove these companies are taking
dictation for government
out of fear of political retribution or
anything else
you can claim that they are state actors
harold the administration is saying that
they're trying to come combat
misinformation because they believe the
vaccination rates in certain areas
and with some groups lower than it needs
to be and should be
because of that misinformation but what
about the tactic
well the tactic thanks for having me on
the tactic
whatever they choose to do facebook or
the white house all of it will be
transparent and done
in the open and i would agree with
kimberly if there's something that is
in violation of the first amendment i
suspect someone will challenge it and
we'll it'll go before court
but one of the chief responsibilities
and obligations of any government
of any president is public health so i
understand where this white house is
coming from we had a few hundred
thousand people
die from this virus and we see the delta
variant on the rise the surgeon general
has every right to push back
and every right to use every tool at his
disposal and certainly
social media platforms are just that now
listen to your interview with senator
hawley
who's a really effective presenter and
he's right on one side as they look at
facebook and some of the
challenges in terms of its size
competitive nature is it suppressing
competitiveness and innovation
those questions need to be answered but
facebook has a process you have to go
through
uh if you find if you you you or i or
anyone on this panel flag something on
facebook that might incite violence or
might bring violence to you or
or create a problem in the community so
i suspect that all of this being done in
the open all of it being done with
transparency on it
uh it'll be hard for them to to to cheat
for that matter to exert
some sort of influence that's undue but
here's the biggest problem and i'm going
to play a sound bite from the head of
the wh right now
and then we'll go on the back side of
that
there was a premature push to
um you know especially
reduce one of the options like the
lab theory as you know
i was a lab technician myself
i'm immunologist and i have worked in
the lab
and lab accidents happen it's common
i have seen it happening and i had i
myself had errors
so it can it can happen
the beginning of the corona virus
pandemic if you said
on facebook or on twitter that there was
a leak
from the lab at wuhan that caused this
coronavirus to spread
that was one of the things listed as
disinformation
if you said at the beginning of the
hunter biden investigation
that this laptop is going to provide
information
that was one of the things that was
disinformation then so as it
evolved it's now not disinformation as
the head of the who just conceded
i'm sorry to disappoint harold but
transparency is not a word i in any way
associate
with any processes when it comes to
facebook flagging misinformation or
disinformation
in fact they are completely opaque in
terms of their processes
what they judge and how they deem things
to be determined
including even their fact checking
process which we previously at the
federalists ran into on exactly this
issue when it came to reporting and
writing about the lab leak hypothesis
and that was something that certainly
frustrated us as a publisher
but it was also far more frustrating
from the perspective of individuals
just trying to share their own thoughts
their own information
and one of the things that i'm really
concerned about when it came to jen
saki's comments today
is she mentioned the fact that this
wasn't just about facebook but about
also
the companies in other areas that they
own they obviously own
the popular messaging component the app
whatsapp
which is something that a lot of people
use to communicate what we saw during
the hunter biden experience was that
people weren't even allowed to direct
message new york post reporting about
that laptop
on twitter is this going to be a similar
circumstance where facebook starts to
reach into
the private communications of
individuals under the guise of
preventing
misinformation disinformation when we
all know that the real reason that
people are seeing these declines
in terms of vaccination rates is the
kind of story that you
had earlier about l.a county about these
school processes
that say regardless of your vaccination
status you're going to have to wear a
mask again
that does much more damage to the cause
of vaccination
than i would say any kind of sharing of
information or debate
around the origination of this virus or
any of the other related issues that
we're discussing
harold i'll go back to you for reaction
here it seems like this is an issue
that the aclu would embrace and say
you're right don't overstep this don't
see the the mixing
of the government and the white house
and this private company that's not
meant that's not controlled or overseen
as a publisher
yeah i mean that's the unfortunate thing
is we used to have a lot more robust
community including groups like the aclu
that would be terrified
if the federal government was in essence
coercing companies this way because
remember the enormous amount of power
the feds have
over outside big tech groups and we now
have democrats in the house who propose
legislation
that would basically require big tech to
get the sign off
of federal regulators for almost any
action they take
and all of this is going to lead
potentially to some really big
lawsuits harold last word
it's not lost on me any of the things
that are being said i would hope that
people would
uh want to get a vaccine because they
want to stop wearing a mask
i would hope people also realize that we
may all get the vaccine and there
may not be enough of us vaccinated that
we may have to go back to wearing it
look
this will all be played out in court i
don't fault this administration for
trying to use every tool possible
to get as many americans vaccinated
because one thing we do know if you're
vaccinated
the chances of you getting sick or worse
from this virus
decreases over one and overwhelming and
dramatic terms to less than 0.1 percent
this is what we should be doing no
american no person in public life in
responsible public life
should be encouraging people not to get
the vaccine so i understand what the
white house is trying to do and if it's
wrong if it's illegal to both of my
panelists look the courts will step in
but i doubt they will
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not gonna miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now